aloha reject nation it's greg alba here
i found out the infinity war trailer is
dropping tomorrow which immediately
fills me personally with a lot of
anxiety i have been waiting for this
trailer for a long time and I'm hearing
it's dropping on Good Morning America
so that means Greg in Pacific Standard
Time it's gonna pull an all-nighter
because it would be easier for me to do
that then it would be to wake up and
look refreshed in the morning to do the
video I'm flippin excited for it the
infinity war trailer teeth drop I was
initially not planning on checking it
out a lot of people were telling me that
it doesn't actually show anything from
the actual trailers they do something
different with the video before I do
that I wanted to give another quick
mention to our sponsors Stardust
Stardust as this app that allows you to
do 30-second reactions for any film TV
show or trailer I know a lot of your
favorite youtubers are using it right
now we're definitely using it every user
pretty much at least every other day and
before we even get our reaction upload
it to YouTube I'll probably do a
starters reaction until you guys my
quick thoughts on it right away anyway
let's check this out
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's a collect that's cool oh come so
long
this is nothing they were ever trained
for
Wow
one day
[Music]
Wow and his hair was different
[Music]
to becoming euros
[Music]
why this is crazy video
[Music]
[Music]
is crazy that was a cool ass video dude
holy crap I guess Marvel likes trailer
reactions for the longest time now we
have been asking for this infinity war
trailer so many people have been
demanding that we get the infinity war
trailer as soon as possible if you see
throw Ragnarok I was like well it makes
sense they will wait to release in a few
weeks after Ragnarok I feel like you
could release this trailer two weeks
before the movie comes out and the
trailer will do really well and the fact
that Marvel put together this trailer
that is all in tribute to fans reactions
of Marvel trailers over the years the
the love for Marvel for over so many
years since you know Iron Man came out
is amazing it's really cool that Marvel
is giving fanservice to fans right now
and that just gets me more excited for
this because infinity war is gonna be
the ultimate fanservice movie I guess my
only question is why the hell wasn't one
of my videos in here wow I don't even a
snippet of me what the hell man I just
open the door for a lot of hate comments
right there well guys tomorrow I will be
one out of 10,000 video reactions that
go up on YouTube hopefully you take the
time to watch mine as well you can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification valve follow us on social
media especially at the Stardust app and
you can check out our patreon become a
patron okay